tollé autour de la nouvelle affaire
nakache jacques chirac relance l'idée de
la libération du terroriste libanais
gouvernement laisse entendre qu'il
s'agit de proposer responsable l'union
soviétique et ses bouleversements pour
la première fois en direct dans ce
journal boris elstine plus populaire que
gorbatchev il fait figure de chef de
l'opposition réformiste
le président mitterrand à varsovie ce
soir dîner officiel offert par le
général jean-yves skis en présence de
dirigeants de solidarité colère dans les
vignes des terres de grave près de
bordeaux menacée par un projet de centre
technologique
madame monsieur bonsoir la drogue
la menace du sida et bientôt un bébé de
plus en plus les maternités en france
sont confrontés aux multiples problèmes
posés par cette équation tragique
ainsi à paris on estime que parmi les
femmes enceintes plus d'une jeune
toxicomane sur deux est séropositif
pire encore un tiers des enfants nés
dans ces conditions sont eux aussi
séropositifs aujourd'hui à paris le
ministre de la santé et la présidente de
la croix rouge ont inauguré le premier
centre d'accueil pour ces mères et ces
enfants là un centre de postcure comme
nous l'expliquent marie-françoise griots
de bibitte en état de manque
privé par la naissance des doses
quotidiennes d'héroïne qu'il partageait
avec sa mère il a dû être transféré dans
une unité spécialisée
il a milité très importantes parfois des
propulsions une perte de poils yens des
dégradations et des troubles digestifs
et dans certains cas ce que réalise de
manière prolongée et pour le traitement
on a en règle besoin d'un substitut du
type et réussir pareille aurait on donne
pendant parfois plusieurs semaines
l'élixir par et gorica base d'opium va
servir à sevrer l'enfant mais ce n'est
pas suffisant car subsiste d'autres
problèmes liés aux conditions de la
grossesse tabac malnutrition sans parler
de l'absence totale de surveillance
médicale
jeune femme est venue à l'hôpital pour
la première fois le jour de son
accouchement son bébé à deux jours il ne
va pas bien
il a dû être transféré en réanimation
néonatale vous a pas gêné de prendre la
droite détention non pas du tout je
culpabilise pas du tout vous aviez déjà
été enceinte auparavant non je me suis
seul je ne sais cher je me suis fait de
la maggia je sais pas j'étais enceinte
j'ai gardé j'ai gardé parce que je peux
pas faire mais c'est tout bon je vous le
dis vous êtes aperçu frotte à vous qui
six mois
non chez en manque
il existe des structures d'accueil pour
celles qui ont décidé d'arrêter la
drogue
le centre de postcure pierre nicol
héberge maintenant les jeunes mères avec
leurs bd mais les soutiens aussi à
chaque étape de leur grossesse
souvent aux 3e 4e mois se cherchant
cents
elles se disent que ça vaut le coup
d'arrêtés la drogue c'est donc l'un des
premiers problèmes
le deuxième c'est celui le
l'accouchement
et puis par la suite l'éducation de
l'enfant avant il n'y avait pas de
motivations réelles des périodes où on
est plus motivé mais il n'y a pas
vraiment quelque chose à quoi se
raccrocher
tandis que là vous si je le fais c'est
pour elle je peux pas la laisser tomber
comme on ça sera un homme c'est pas
pareil il peut se débrouiller
ll es petit tu retires je lui dis j'en
ai pris pour 20 ans et 20 ans de prison
mais ses ventes tant d'éducation de ma
fille
quelle mouche a donc piqué jacques
chirac c'est la question que se pose en
termes plus ou moins virulent tous ceux
qui en france se préoccupe des affaires
de terrorisme
hier soir vous allez l'entendre l'ancien
premier ministre disait à des élèves de
l'essec qui l'ont filmé qu'il fallait
peut-être libéré le terroriste libanais
anis naccache nakache est en prison
condamné à perpétuité et son cas depuis
deux ans entretient une polémique
ambiguë entre jacques chirac et les
socialistes
ce soir le tollé est presque général
hervé brusini et gilles leclair
réjean complices dès qu'on démolisse
sept ans va s'interroger si vous manque
t il refaire quelque chose étant donné
les iraniens qu'ils avaient demandé
un chien de la casse les gens de l'otage
si j'avais jusqu'à faire le moindre
cadeau
c'est moi
à cette suggestion le ministre de
l'intérieur répliqué ce matin par le
silence l'ancien premier ministre du
chah lui en revanche était un peu plus
loquace
monsieur chirac il était tout de même
premier ministre à prendre dans deux ans
ils auraient pu pousser le cadenas cost
un peu plus loin et arriver à une
solution
il a pas fait à temps pourquoi il
revient à la salle en fait rien pour
chapour bakhtiar le nom d'annie stack h
est loin d'être inconnu
le soldat de khomeiny avait tenté de
l'assassiner en 1980 à l'époque le
commando avait fait deux morts
depuis les poseurs de bombes du
hezbollah dont la cache se réclament
on fait de sa libération leur cheval de
bataille un temps le sort de nos otages
semblait lié à celui de nakache
le chef de l'état lui même reconnaissait
avoir envisagé les changes entre tous
les otages français du liban et nakache
mais on le sait il n'y eu aucune suite
et puis ce fut en février dernier le
coup de théâtre face à roland dumas le
ministre iranien des affaires étrangères
velayati rappelé que la libération de
nakache avait été promise par le
gouvernement chirac
jusqu'ici aucune preuve n'a été apportée
sur ce point du fond de sa prison de
fresnes nakache lui n'a pas cessé de
lancer communiquer sur communiqué
aujourd'hui les experts de
l'antiterrorisme affirment qu'ils n'ont
enregistré pour l'instant aucune menace
déclaré de terrorisme d'état
officiellement selon l'hôtel de ville
jacques chirac n'a pas d'informations
particulières concernant l'éventuelle
menace d'attentats tout au plus
souligne-t-on ici le maire de paris a
voulu exprimer un sentiment un avis
qu'il a voulu donner hier soir à des
étudiants au cours d'une conversation en
fait pour jacques chirac il ya peut-être
que même aujourd'hui un problème
alice nakache le terroriste libanais à
ses yeux à d'abord passé sept ans en
prison
ensuite le contexte politique au
moyen-orient a pu évoluer
cela dit l'hôtel de ville ici ce soir ne
veut pas attacher trop d'importance aux
paroles du maire de paris
il n'empêche ce soir on continue à
s'interroger sur le pourquoi
aujourd'hui de tels propos et dans les
milieux politiques de simone veil à jean
marie le pen en passant par lionel
jospin condamnation des propos de
l'ancien premier ministre
réaction plus embarrassé du côté du
centre et de l'udf valéry giscard
d'estaing se refuse à tout commentaire
tout en rappelant que le droit de casse
appartient au président de la république
espoirs ce soit pour un otage belge au
liban un médecin ian cole enlevés il ya
plus d'un an une organisation
clandestine qui a revendiqué son rapt
annonce sans plus de précisions son
intention de le libérer
treize morts 270 blessés c'est le bilan
des attentats qui entre décembre 85 et
septembre 86 avait ensanglanté paris où
en est l'enquêté en sont les modalités
d'indemnisation des victimes
le juge boulouque qui conduit le dossier
depuis trois ans a réuni aujourd'hui au
palais de justice de paris
toutes les victimes qui se sont portés
parties civiles
isabelle steiss dominique verdeilhan 14
heures devant le palais de justice
presque tous sont au rendez vous 75
parties civiles des attentats de 86
seules les victimes qui aujourd'hui ne
peuvent plus se déplacer n'ont pu
répondre à la convocation du juge bout
pour témoigner du respect de la justice
à leur égard pendant trois heures
le magistrat s'est enfermé avec les
victimes afin de les informer des
résultats de son enquête
je pense que j'ai eu beaucoup qu'après
bien fait de réunir les victimes
d'attentats et dix sont portés donc
partie civile et de leur demander
d'un point de vue et de répondre à leurs
questions c'est une chose qui se fait
habituellement pas et c'est tout à son
honneur de l'avoir
on nous a raconté comment s'étaient dire
et le
la manigance de la santa la préparation
entre liban et tout ce qui s'ensuit
si on le savait on l'avait su lee la
presse ont écouté la télévision et tout
jamais
et ce n'est pas les gens qu'on applique
maman
à la fin du lycée unique
à l'heure des comptes le fonds de
solidarité a annoncé qu'il a déjà versé
14 millions de francs d'indemnités
certaines victimes n'ont encore rien
touché quand c'est des ministres ce
matin michel rocard a reçu
l'autorisation d'engager la
responsabilité de son gouvernement pour
faire adopter le projet de loi sur
l'audiovisuel public qui sera examiné
par l'assemblée en début de semaine
prochaine
le chef de l'état surtout insisté sur
l'importance des célébrations du
bicentenaire en présence de nombreux
chefs d'état et de gouvernement
étrangers
des propos qui vise sans doute à
assourdir la polémique que l'on entend
ici ou là et que le premier ministre a
répété tout à l'heure and assemblée
nationale je préfère vous dire carrément
oui il y aura une gêne oui elle peut
être sensible dans une partie paris nous
le savons mais une fois une fois au
moins dans notre vie nos ont vu le coeur
de paris sans voiture sans camion sans
gaz d'échappement sans moteur bédard ap
d'aradan et cela pendant plusieurs jours
les problèmes
les inconvénients les tracas je suis sûr
qu'ils sont oubliés au plus tard quelque
chose après tandis que dureront
longtemps le souvenir de paris sans
voiture le souvenir des grandes
décisions qui se prépare pour le sommet
des sept et le souvenir la fête
si nous savons la vivre merci c'est une
première le président mitterrand est en
visite officielle en pologne séjour est
un symbole très attendue par le régime
comme par solidarité qui est représenté
ce soir au dîner officiel que le général
jean usé ce qui offre en ce moment même
en l'honneur du chef de l'état français
georges bortoli et sur place le général
et madame jaruzelski monsieur rakowski
premier ministre d'un gouvernement
auquel les élections ne laisse aucune
chance de survie toute la pologne
officiels étaient là pour accueillir ces
d'après midi me chez madame mitterrand
c'est la première fois qu'un président
français vient à varsovie depuis onze
ans c'est la première fois aussi que
monsieur mitterrand personnellement be
site la pologne mais c'est la deuxième
fois qu'il rencontre le général
jaruzelski puisque celui ci avait fait
escale à paris en décembre 1985 à la fin
d'une longue période d'isolement
diplomatique ou la pologne cd trouvait
enfermé à la suite de l'état siègent
donc c'est la visite des retrouvailles
franco polonaise confortée par
l'évolution actuelle vers plus de
démocratie
confortée en particulier par la
réhabilitation de solidarité par les
premières élections schumi démocratique
que la pologne est connu depuis 40 ans
monsieur mitterrand veut rendre aux
relations franco polonaise leur
caractère traditionnel c'est-à-dire
amicale voire chaleureuse
cette marche vers la démocratie n'est
encore qu'amorcer puisque le parti
communiste sorti battu des urnes restent
pourtant pouvoir
monsieur mitterrand l'a juste content
suffisamment important pour mériter
d'être soutenu ce nom comment soutenir
la pologne si on ne soutient pas d'abord
son économie qui est vraiment au bord du
gouffre voilà pourquoi au cours de cette
visite à laquelle prend part monsieur
bérégovoy ministre de l'économie on va
parler sûrement finances et peut-être
notamment de la reprise des prêts
français à moyen terme vers la pologne
mikhaïl gorbatchev lui termine ce soir
une visite triomphale en allemagne
fédérale tout à l'heure encore à
stuttgart le président soviétique a eu
droit à l'accueil enthousiaste de la
foule et des politiciens locaux
de son côté le gouvernement ouest
allemand a dressé un premier bilan
positif de cette visite tout en restant
très prudent sur la question de la
réunification de l'allemagne
l'union soviétique mené par la vision et
la poigne d'un homme change en
profondeur on observe depuis deux ans
maintenant
depuis que mikhaïl gorbatchev a pris
progressivement en main la direction du
pays et ce changement s'accélère dans
les difficultés et même dans les remous
alors à quoi ressemble les nouveaux
russes c'est le thème de l'émission qui
s'annonce passionnante et que daniel
leconte et jean claude guillebaud nous
présenterons tout al heure de moscou
parmi leurs invités
un homme le seul à être plus populaire
en union soviétique mikhaïl gorbatchev
il s'appelle boris elstine il avait été
limogé de ses responsabilités à moscou
pour cause de réformisme aiguë il vient
d'être élu triomphalement au congrès des
députés du peuple et pour la première
fois ce soir il va s'exprimer en direct
sur une télévision occidentale le ciel
si une bon soir bonsoir
vous ne ménagez pas vos critiques à
l'égard de mikhaïl gorbatchev que vous
accusez souvent de melesse est ce que
vous vous considérez vous de fait comme
le chef d'une opposition réformiste
et bien je ne me considère pas comme le
chef d'une opposition mais je considère
c'est que j'ai simplement des opinions
qui diffère des positions du kama
rockeur bacio ce n'est pas cela
l'opposition
c'est simplement mon propre point de vue
sur les processus qui se déroule dans
notre société et sur les méthodes pour
surmonter la crise parti existe chez
nous dans la société aussi bien que dans
le parti a pris mon dieu si je critique
de caméras gorbatchev 5e pas dire que je
sois dans l'opposition ça veut dire
simplement que j'ai des opinions
alternative des opinions alternative
dans un système politique qui le moins
que l'on puisse dire n'est pas encore
pluraliste ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que tout simplement que ce
sont des opinions qui diffère de celle
de gorbatchev et quelles sont vos
relations personnelles avec gorbatchev
monsieur ly sin enfin nous avons des
relations d'affaires si vous voulez mais
elles pourraient être meilleurs et donc
vous attendez de lui qu'il se rapproche
de vaud de vos vues qu'il qu'il agisse
plus vite dans le sens des réformes que
vous souhaitez
hier moigne escobar swiss cazaux
plusieurs fois je lui exposer ma
position concernant le fait que la
pérestroïka se limite souvent à des demi
mesures
on peut dire que d'une certaine façon il
m'a écouté et il a écouté certaines de
ses opinions mais a néanmoins il
continue à prendre des demi mesures et
non pas des mesures radicales pour
renouveler la société c'est pourquoi je
ne suis pas satisfait quand vous voyez
ce qui se passe en pologne et en chine
deux exemples tout à fait
contradictoires de ce qui se passe dans
le monde communiste
vous pensez vous qu'il est possible
qu'il est nécessaire de mener de front
les réformes économiques et les réformes
politiques et bien résisté tu réellement
faut tout d'abord mettre en oeuvre la
réforme du système politique
la suite cette réforme on pourra
réformer l'économie
on pourra également améliorer le niveau
de vie du peuple
c'est là à votre avis la priorité numéro
un dans votre pays
l'amélioration du niveau de vie
absolument c'est l'objectif final
monsieur helsinn merci on vous
retrouvera tout à l'heure à à 22h15 très
exactement en direct de moscou avec jean
claude guillebaud et vous daniel leconte
pour une émission vraiment sans
précédent daniel qu'est-ce qu'il vous
avez raison de le dire c'est une
émission sans précédent puisque c'est la
première fois qu'un grand magazine
d'information se fait en direct de
moscou avec je dirais toute
l'infrastructure de la télévision
soviétique c'est à dire qu'on a ici on
essaie dans le studio de la grande
émission d'information regard avec des
techniciens soviétiques avec des
cameramans soviétique avec des chefs de
plateau soviétique
et tout ça vous l'imaginez bien pose des
problèmes de communication des façons de
travailler de langage en gros si vous
voulez on a voulu jouer la transparence
dans les faits dans l'émission alors
bien sûr dans l'émission il y aura aussi
comme d'habitude dans l'histoire
immédiate des reportages faits à partir
d'ailleurs du livre de claude marie
vadrot les nouveaux russes et puis des
invités vous avez dit monsieur monsieur
il signera monsieur pop up
il ya en tout 18 invité des invités de
la société civile et nous des bretons de
avec eux de la question de la période
troïka des nouveaux russes avec eux ce
soir
alors rendez vous à tout le monde à
22h15 rendez vous donc à 22h15 et si
l'on en juge d'après la vigueur et la
franchise des propos de monsieur helsinn
cette émission va vraiment signifier
pour nous en france que la pérestroïka
est la transparence fonctionne en union
soviétique non plus vous christine c'est
vrai je le regrette bien en chine
en revanche en chine le régime s'en
prend de plus en plus ouvertement à la
presse étrangère et surtout américaines
deux journalistes américains ont été
expulsés aujourd'hui les relations
deviennent difficiles entre washington
et pékin
selon certains journaux avec elle les
états unis auraient proposé au régime
chinois de laisser partir le dissident
fans l'isi et sa femme réfugiée dans
leur ambassade de les laisser partir
pour un pays tiers
mais ces rumeurs ne sont pas confirmées
ce soir par ailleurs la vague
d'arrestations continue deux dirigeants
étudiants qui figurait sur la liste
noire ont été pris l'un d'eux a tout
simplement été dénoncé par sa propre
soeur gilles rabin géo fonction a été
dénoncé par sa soeur jody jambe juste
après la diffusion de l'avis de
recherche contre ce leader étudiant
sa soeur a appelé le bureau de sécurité
publique pour l'informer que son frère
s'était réfugié chez elle cinq agents de
police sont immédiatement venus
l'arrêter à domicile cette histoire
édifiante pour les autorités de pékin a
été montré plusieurs fois depuis hier à
la télévision chinoise qui consacre la
quasi-totalité de ses programmes
d'information à la délation et à la
répression
on a même pu voir hier soir un enfant
non c'est ses parents toute nouvelle
arrestation est aussitôt film et
commenter les étudiants et les ouvriers
qui ont pris part au mouvement de
protestation sont longuement exhibées
devant les caméras officielles tête
baissée deux forces
partout et toujours cette même volonté
d'humilier publiquement ce que le
pouvoir considère comme des
contre-révolutionnaires et paris a
décidé de renouveler tous les visas des
étudiants chinois qui séjournent en
france ils sont à peu près 3000 qui
auront ainsi le temps de réfléchir à
leur retour au pays
à genève la conférence des nations unies
sur les réfugiés indochinois s'est
terminée dans l'ambiguïté et l'amertume
seule la france les états unis le
vietnam se sont formellement opposés aux
rapatriements forcés des boat people
le représentant vietnamien a fait
sensation en reconnaissant tout à
l'heure devant des journalistes
la faillite du système politique et
sociale de son pays seule solution at il
dit l'ouverture politique raid israélien
ce matin dans la montagne druze au sud
est de beyrouth un double raid qui
visait les positions de deux
organisations palestiniennes et qui a
fait trois morts
à beyrouth les bombardements ont
continué toute la journée
l'émissaire arabes chargés de trouver un
règlement à la crise est reparti pour
damas sans résultat
les élections européennes elles auront
lieu demain pour les britanniques les
irlandais les danois les hollandais et
les espagnols demain jeudi et non pas
dimanche comme pour nous mais les
résultats seront publiés en même temps
dimanche soir ou lundi matin
poursuivons donc notre tour d'europe
après l'italie et la grande bretagne
comment cette campagne urbaine s'est
elle déroulée en espagne
quels en sont les enjeux michel
mompontet depuis que je joue tous les
soirs sur les deux chaînes de la
télévision nationale espagnole
quelle idée le dernier enfant a chanté
l'hymne à la joie dans ce parlement de
strasbourg
le fera bien sûr en espagnol
l'importance de ce vote pour l'espagne
et dc visibles dans les rues des
milliers d' affiches pour trente trois
listes en présence des milliers de
slogans comme pour exorciser le fantôme
de l'abstention qui effraie toute la
classe politique locale
felipe gonzalez a choisi hier soir pour
son dernier meeting les arènes de madrid
c'est ici disons que se font les gloires
les aussi les boums il coupera at il
assuré à ses militants demain et deux
oreilles et la queue
à moins que l'abstention et cetera et
cetera
en fait les bookmakers de madrid ce soir
ne parie pas sur le résultat des
élections de demain mais plutôt sur la
météo
on annonce 40 degrés de même dans la
capitale espagnole
40 ça pourrait être aussi le pourcentage
des abstentions comme quoi expression
démocratique et météo sont souvent
intimement liées le poids de la campagne
en france maintenant en quatre jours du
scrutin
après le socialiste et le verre
recyclant bruno roger-petit analyse la
campagne du communiste philippe herzog
philippe herzog attend patients et
silencieux il attend qu andré duroméa
maire du havre membre du pc depuis plus
de 45 ans est achevé son discours
respect dus par le cadet à son aîné en
communisme une réunion intimes comme les
aime philippe herzog il peut expliquer
démontrer argumenté sous l'oeil paternel
d'andré duroméa discrètement l'aîné juge
le cas dès le premier intellectuel à
défendre les couleurs du parti dans une
élection nationale
une ovation peut-être une rénovation on
parle beaucoup de rénovations dans les
partis politiques en ce moment vous
pensez qu'un jour monsieur herzog
pourrait être le dirigeant communiste de
l'an 2000 pourquoi pas je lis pas dans
le marc de café
mais en tout cas il al'étoffe pour le
faire à l'aise en petit comité philippe
herzog l'est beaucoup moins en meeting
il est vrai qu'il lui faut compter
souvent avec la présence voire
l'omniprésence de georges marchais mais
philippe herzog a su s'habituer à
l'ombre du secrétaire général et à la
tribune s'il n'est pas l'homme des
grandes envolées lyriques
il s'est fait entendre sa condamnation
de l'europe de 92 l'emploi précaire à
vis de bas salaires et aucune
perspective de carrière sauf pour une
élite
c'est ça l'europe de beaux rêves
c'est ça qu'on veut car si on le veut il
faut voter giscard veille fabius ou le
pen
l'infatigable intellectuelle philippe
herzog entrera au parlement européen le
18 juin après une campagne dont il
aurait été peut-être lui et lui seul
la principale novation communiste comme
tous les ans et lyon les lauréats du
concours général tous ces jeunes gens
brillants qui font honneur à leurs
études et à leur niche et et cette fois
encore c'est le lycée louis le grand à
paris qui avec 13 prix et accessits
devine palmarès chantal kimmerlin
couronné des premiers prix aux meilleurs
accessits dans toutes les matières
c'est tout est bien fait donc mais cette
tête qui n'ont pas trop la grosse tête
ça m'a fait plaisir une surprise cherche
non pas trop points si on prend simple
comme un espèce de jeu un amusement
onces à un défi se dire oui pourquoi pas
après tout le lycée faut faire ça pour
lui ici alors on le fait si on prends ça
comme un jeu mon dieu ça devient très
agréable et on les laisse prix tout à
fait détendus depuis 20 ans louis
legrand décroche un maximum de prix au
concours général avec 19 lauréats cette
année c'est le nirvana et dans quelques
jours on peut s'attendre à 99 % de
réussite au bac
il n'y a pas de secret excusez pour la
sélection scolaire aurait mauvaise grâce
d'être contre nous parce que
effectivement on a tous fait jusqu'ici
grâce va pas grâce à la section fallait
pas la sélection scolaire
il me sens effectivement que ce pas une
nécessité mais à partir d'un niveau oui
il ya une vie privée une petite amie dit
non
la vie n'est pas cassée lecture j'aime
beaucoup dans le théâtre
j'aime beaucoup le théâtre et et puis la
littérature aussi le sport non c'est pas
du tout moi je suis pas comme ça une
passion passion patients les maths le
théâtre ciné club
oui patients les maths plutôt tout de
même fini rail au village et en famille
pour albert spaggiari aujourd'hui à ne
pas signer
inhumation cet après-midi d'albert
spaggiari cerveau du gang des égoutiers
qui avait volé 46 millions de francs à
la société générale de nice en 76 les
obsèques ont eu lieu dans son village
natal de laragne en présence de sa mère
et de son ex-femme
ouverture aujourd'hui à la cour
d'assises des bouches du rhône du procès
de jean-pierre aveline gardiens de la
paix qui comparaît pour coups mortels
il avait tué en février 88 sur un
parking de marseille christian de 0 26
ans qui l'avaient pris pour un voleur
au cours de l'audience le faire de la
victime accusé les policiers d'avoir
tout fait pour lui cacher la vérité
puis-je à la saline le commandant de
bord de l'airbus a320 d'habsheim 1 qu'il
fait aujourd'hui d'homicide involontaire
l'accident de l'avion qu'il pilotait au
cours d'un meeting aérien en juin 88
avait fait trois morts en mai dernier
michel assouline dénoncé le trucage des
boîtes noires il est resté semble si
aujourd'hui très en retrait de ces
accusations
il mobilise et les boeing 737 400 c'est
la recommandation des constructeurs
boeing et csm suite aux incidents
survenus à deux appareils britanniques
de ce type vendredi et dimanche dernier
trente quatre boeing 737 400 sont
actuellement en service
photo kc les grands vignobles français
dans notre patrimoine national
la question se pose à nouveau dans le
bordelais où les viticulteurs s'oppose
farouchement à un projet sacrilège
la construction d'une d'un centre de
technologie sur des terres de graves qui
ne sont pas utilisés actuellement pour
la vigne mais qui sont de qualité and
gas berger château le pape château
haut-bailly château la louvière lait cru
classé de graves sorte de ses vignes
tout un prestige aujourd'hui menacée de
la bergerie de montesquieu il ne reste
que des roses
le tracteur doit maintenant faire face
au bulldozer une course contre la montre
contre la crête technopole qui avance il
faut faire vite défricher cultivé et
faire classer la vigne c'est la seule
protection car les chenilles mécanique
il s'attaque pour l'instant aux friches
réserve d'un terroir dont le caillou est
exceptionnel
démolir un patrimoine comme celui ci
c'est c'est véritablement de la boulimie
technologique il faut bien travailler le
moïse a et on va pourquoi on vient
démolir ce qui est unique et surtout qui
n'est pas inépuisable
on ne peut pas indéfiniment retrouver
les graver sur les à une fois qu'on les
a démoli pour les transformer en route
un chemin un laboratoire c'est fini pour
la visite un projet né en 85 du rêve
d'un ingénieur à terme sa zone
technologique confisquera 450 hectares
de terres de grande valeur là même où
depuis 15 ans les viticulteurs
investissent et se bat pour enrichir
l'économie régionale c'est viscéral si
vous voulez cet attachement au sol et à
la terre et bien entendu tout ce qui
porte atteinte à ce patrimoine
c'est quelque chose qui nous touche
énormément il ya sans doute encore des
réserves très importantes très
importante beaucoup plus important que
certains vignobles accompli comme le
pomerol par exemple or je crois que on
peut arriver à concilier à la fois
l'intérêt du développement économique de
l'agglomération et celui que nous venons
respecté de la viticulture
après avoir été convoité par des
investisseurs étrangers le vignoble est
aujourd'hui rongé par les tentacules des
villes de demain les secrets de ces
châteaux seront peut être livré aux
ambitions des promoteurs
voilà dans un instant laurent cabrol va
vous parler du temps de demain vous avez
rendez-vous à 22h10 avec henri sannier
qui en direct de madrid à l'occasion des
élections européennes vous présentera
donc notre dernier journal et puis à
22h30 à 22h30 donc en direct de moscou
rendez vous avec daniel leconte et jean
claude guillebaud pour une émission sur
les nouveaux russes une émission en
direct demain
bien sûr à partir de 6h30 rendez vous
avec télématin et j'en ai le plaisir de
vous retrouver demain à 20 heures
très bonne soirée seront tenus
oh